o of pine biotech
uh mr elijah broski
he is one of the co-founders of the pion
biotech company
elia's background is in is in applied
mathematics and data sign
he is currently completing his degree in
business and management from tulane
university
he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
istanbul
louisiana state university tulane and
other academic and pharma r d teams
mr broski oversees the strategic
development of research projects and
manages the teams responsible for
bioinformatics analysis training and
collaborations for time biotech
dr mohit masunder
has over 12 years of experience in and
in research and industry
he completed a master's in
bioinformatics from jamia media islamia
and a phd in computational biology and
chemistry
from
jaguar nehru university
he is an expert in machine learning
application to biomedical and chemical
data he is currently heading the global
business development for time biotech
usa and contributing to bioinformatic
research and education
by collaborating with universities in
india and africa and mentoring
participants from various programs
by providing bioinformatic research
supporting applying statistical and
algorithmic approaches
we thank
the sponsors
for this activity puerto rico inbree
university of puerto rico medical
francis campus and napie amix logic
pr imbre and the talbot bioinformatics
research center
please elia proceed
okay thank you very much for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
having us today
i want to start by briefly
sharing uh some background information
about uh nepi for those of you that are
not familiar nepi is the national
association of idea principal
investigators
and as a part of this organization
it connects the idea community so the
idea community
are the
states
23 states including puerto rico
that
are funded through the nih to elevate
the level of biomedical research and you
can find some more information about
this uh organization on the website
nappy.org
and i'm thank you
and i'm uh here uh presenting today's
session
on behalf of nepy essentially because uh
some of the materials and resources that
we will cover today are being offered to
nepe
and so to uh briefly explain uh what
neppy's objective is in this program
i will also share maybe a link or just
if you could share the link to the nepe
website
that explains essentially what our
program is designed to achieve
which is provide training and link
resources across this network to offer
elevated access to
biomedical research
using computational tools and
bioinformatics
okay let me
start my presentation
okay so
what i want to share with you today is
uh the project-based training in
bioinformatics and data science
that we have designed to address a gap
in skills and resources that we think
exists
across these 23 states and puerto rico
primarily starting from the
undergraduate level and offered as an
integrated path from learning to
research
and so
before we begin talking about what
exactly this program includes i want to
introduce you to a portal that we
designed to
make sure that these resources are
widely accessible and effective
using our asynchronous portal called
omixlogic so if you please go to
learn.omixlogic.com
and i believe that the link to the
portal will also be available in the
chat
you will find here
that uh you know we explain kind of what
what this portal is all about biology as
a data science on the front page and i
will walk you today through some of the
resources that this portal includes and
how this activity can be used for
training and preparation of students for
research activity using bioinformatics
and computational biology and then later
on i will pass it on to dr mohit
mazumdar who will speak about some of
the ongoing programs that we currently
have offered through the louisiana
biomedical research network and now
being available to the nepe community as
well as some of the upcoming events and
resources that are scheduled for the
spring and the summer of 2022.
so if anyone wants to understand how
this portal works it's always useful to
start with creating a profile
so you will see that there's a login
button and it's very easy to create an
account and so i will encourage you to
just try it out yourself right now if
you can go and create an account
right here as you click on sign in it's
a free sign in
you then create an account by clicking
this button and the first thing that you
will see is that everything that we will
be discussing today is focused on that
user profile so you'll be able to see
how this portal works and i will
introduce some of the elements that we
use in training for different types of
omics data analysis and data science
so
once you log in
you will notice
that there is going to be a user profile
so right here on the top you will find
your email address
and in that email address you will find
all of this activity related to your
user profile and we use this information
in part to validate that the user
participants are a part of the nepi
network because for them all of this
training is available for free
throughout 2022
so i'll give you just a moment here to
sign in and i will switch over
to
my own account just to illustrate how
this works
okay so
learn
productslogic.com
if i log out you will see right here on
top of the screen you will see a login
button
and here you can create an account
and you can either use your email and
create a password
or
you can sign in with one of your social
media accounts
so i already have an account i'm going
to just sign in
and after you're signed in you will be
redirected to either different levels of
access
so you can skip that
or
to this part of the portal that lists
out the different coursework that we
have so today i'll briefly introduce
some of these resources but i wanted to
start from this overview of your account
so on this account
you will find your personal activity
and certification as you complete some
of the coursework
so what we've realized
working with the louisiana biomedical
research network as well as with other
states is that expertise in
bioinformatics is really
not distributed equitably or equally
throughout the different regions where
we interact with students in fact what
we've noticed is that there's a big gap
in even understanding of the role of
bioinformatics and data science in many
aspects of biomedical research
and the challenge i think is that we
don't introduce these concepts early
enough in the
kind of horizons of the students that
are joining
research projects and so as a result
there's a gap in skills when those
students want to participate in
meaningful research you want to involve
them in a research study in a grant
proposal or collaboration they are not
equipped to deal with data and so to
introduce different aspects of skills
including technical skills as well as
conceptual skills or what we call the
logic behind omics data we've designed
this portal that seeks to address the
gap in in skills and the understanding
of how biomedical data could be analyzed
to produce meaningful insights and one
of the things that we are
working on is a certification provided
through regional as well as local
institutions for example lbrn the
louisiana biomedical research network
would be a research a regional
institution and llsu louisiana state
university would be a local entity
they can provide training certificates
that validate that the student is ready
or a researcher essentially is ready to
participate in
all aspects of research that include
bioinformatics one of the ways that we
do this is through our tracking system
that looks at different aspects of
participation activity and skill sets
that are covered in the different topics
that are introduced throughout the
portal
an important component of that is a
project so a lot of times
when we try to understand if a student
is ready to participate in a project
it's not enough to just have basic
skills like coding and r or statistical
analysis what we really want to
understand is whether a student is ready
to understand the question the research
question and the approach that could be
taken using data to address that
question and so a big part of what we
are trying to do is design a system that
leads from basic training which is skill
based training
to
research based training which is project
oriented and so this project process
that we've designed here starts from
completing your profile and presenting
yourself to the world that goes to
earning a certain number of points which
validates that you have the technical
skills and then eventually it gives you
access to a specific course
that addresses common challenges that
people face in designing and developing
an independent project using
bioinformatics and computational biology
tools
so as a result
what we see is that those students that
are able to complete a project and here
we have
sorry i'll go back to here here we have
an example of what this project
structure looks like you can see that it
actually prepares a student to think
about their research presentation for a
poster session or even a publication and
i think that's really a critical need
that we all face in
giving access to research projects and
involving students especially
undergraduate students in biomedical
research that is ongoing right we want
them to understand the format we want
them to understand reproducibility of
research and we want them to be able to
describe the methodology and the
approaches that they take in technical
language that is uh you know brief and
and something that we can all review
so that is an essential part of the
training that we provide
and uh to be able to get to that level
to be able to address uh kind of the
place where students commonly are when
they begin this training and where they
should be when we anticipate them to be
ready to participate in meaningful
research we provide a curriculum
that is organized by several different
subjects
so first of all we have different topics
that we cover including
methods of analysis for example
statistical analysis on machine learning
types of data genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics and metagenomics as well as
different levels for example getting
started or trying to address a skill in
r coding or python coding and eventually
getting into a project and projects here
refer to publications that are digested
curated data sets from that publication
are extracted and reproducible methods
of analysis that follow the paper method
section are given as a tutorial
so to get started with these we organize
a
getting started or introduction to
bioinformatics curriculum that anyone
can try
use for themselves or utilize for their
training and introduction to students
that don't have
even the basics of bioinformatics
as of now
so the introduction to bioinformatics
consists of
several different modules they're all
organized under this getting started
section
and they include
introduction to bioinformatics which is
a course that speaks about the
applications of bioinformatics in
different domains like health care
pharmaceutical industry basic and
translational research environmental
research and others
it also covers the basic terminology
that connects biological concepts and
data science concepts or information
technology concepts in a course that we
call bytes and molecules so the course
is designed to introduce terminology and
the basic concepts that one has to know
to be able to continue and pursue
bioinformatics or computational biology
as a practical skill
and then we offer two simple courses in
bioinformatics and r and bioinformatics
in python that are designed to
show how easy it is to start with coding
for someone that has minimal or no
background at all in coding and
has
some immediate applications to the types
of challenges that one might face
dealing with biological data
now apart from that we will talk today
about several other resources that we
utilize inside this training that help
build the logic of analysis
focused on big data
so we are
following this
specific
two directional approach one direction
is practical skills and those include
concepts terminology understanding
critical thinking and then we also
introduced this other dimension which is
the logic of analysis and how to apply
some of these concepts to large data
sets that typically you would not be
able to handle on your own on your own
system and so those technical
limitations are eliminated on our uh
tbionfor platform that i'll discuss in a
moment
importantly like i mentioned all of
these topics are introduced in the
context of projects right because one of
the things that we realized is that it's
very difficult for somebody who's
interested let's say in infectious and
communicable diseases to understand the
specific applications of bioinformatics
in a context that is completely
different let's say in environmental
data or
maybe
cancer data right so we want to make
those applications as closely related to
the type of interest that the student
might already have and so we organize
our
different tutorials under projects and
those projects could be divided into
different sections
so what we
started with this year
is offering six basic training modules
and these six basic training modules are
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and data science so these are offered as
year-long
curricula that you can organize into an
asynchronous or a live
type course
our team supports it and actually runs a
number of these programs throughout the
year and dr mizunder will be speaking
about some of these programs when i'm
done with my part of the presentation
[Music]
in addition to that we also provide
specialization tracks and these include
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture
and agriculture
includes also some elements of
biotechnology
so what we
are trying to do is develop exemplar
projects with curated data sets and an
explanation of methods that are sourced
from
impactful publications in that domain
to illustrate how some of those basic
data types as well as methods could be
applied to solve real research
challenges
now let me briefly explain what is the
difference between what i am describing
as a curriculum or as a content database
and some of the practical resources that
are included in this program and in this
training
so the omics logic program resources are
really designed around
training materials
computational tools that are easy to use
that biologists can use
interactive coding exercises that could
be first of all checked for syntax and
second of all checked for the correct
results and then finally an introduction
to a coding environment where you can
take some of the scripts that you've
learned how to write and then execute
them on a big data infrastructure
so let me briefly introduce some of
these resources in greater detail
one
resource that is very critical for a
biologist to get started
is no code bioinformatics
and that means that you can use
bioinformatics without writing a single
line of code
and for that purpose we have a big data
analysis platform
that is
not unlike galaxy and some of the other
tools that exist out there but it is
tightly integrated with the curriculum
that we have designed for different
types of data and i'll briefly show this
platform today so that you can all get a
sense of what it really looks like and
how it works
the second part of this tutorial
approach is incorporating data science
and that means coding exercises that
check your ability to write correct
syntax without errors
and provide you with specific results to
the coding challenges so that you can
understand how to get the desired
outcome in your code
following a tutorial
and then finally we also are building a
network of mentors that can help you
take those skills further and so
essentially by working on exemplar
projects and trying to identify research
questions that could be answered with
data analysis skills we can then
eventually match you to a research
experience in which you can try to
understand a topic with the help of a
mentor that will eliminate some of the
dead ends and guide you to identify a
low-hanging fruit in terms of being able
to answer a research question as an
experience for you to gain computational
biology research skills
let me briefly
show you the resource that i mentioned
before
so right here if you go under courses
on the portal and by now i hope that
most of you have already created an
account i saw that some people joined
maybe a little bit late so i'll just
remind everyone this is a portal that we
are speaking about called omixlogic so
you can log in by following the link
learn.omixlogic.com
login is free you can gain access to
most of the resources for free and if
you are a part of one of our programs
through the nepe the national
association of idea principal
investigators you can gain access to all
of the resources that are mentioning
today for free using the nepi contract
that our company has
so here you will find
different types of courses materials and
projects
right here you will find different tags
that you can try
and below are
collections that you can find focused on
different types of data different types
of skills
and one of those skills is the tbion for
platform that really establishes the
logic of analysis
applicable to big data
so what is this platform
this platform and by the way anyone that
wants to demo account on this platform
after you have registered on the learn
portal and you have received your
password in your email
after 24 hours you will gain automatic
access to this platform
just to explore and see what it can do
so this platform is organized according
to several different sections you can
see here transcriptomics genomics
epigenomics
and different methods of analysis listed
on this side
there's also sections related to mass
spectroscopy and structural biology
there are specific sections an
application to cancer biology single
cell analysis virology as well as data
integration and modeling so as you look
through these different sections you'll
find that some of them have a drop down
button
and this drop down button gives you
access to a demo pipeline builder that
you can try without having to upload any
data and without having to perform the
actual analysis so here for example you
will find that informative pop-ups that
are associated with each step of the
analysis will guide you
to build meaningful combinations of
scripts and algorithms that will produce
results that you can use so for example
in this transcriptomic section you can
see that i can perform mapping using
bowtie and then visualize the sam file
of the mapping that i performed and in
addition to this visualization i can
also find resources on the learn portal
that will allow me to
to understand what exactly i'm trying to
do
so this is just an example again you can
see that in many sections there's a drop
down that you can find different types
of
different types of
you know methods of analysis and
different types of pipelines
that you can perform
so you can try and use that demo account
once you have created a login
so again that could be found
using coursework on tbioinfo and you can
see here a collection of courses that
you can explore and really learn how to
perform analysis of metagenomic genomic
transcriptomic and other types of data
now to illustrate how these kinds of
methods are used in a in a training
experience i want to briefly talk about
several different types of programs that
we run throughout the year and then i
will pass it on to dr mizunder to speak
about specific programs that we have
running right now starting in the end of
january
so a good example of a program that we
regularly run is a program on
transcriptomic data analysis and so we
call this bulk and single cell
transcriptomics
the program is designed to introduce the
omix technologies including how the
library preparation happens how the
actual sequencing happens how does the
understanding of the methods of data
preparation uh impact our analysis
approaches to that data
and
ultimately how to then use some of this
methodology to actually be able to
perform
large-scale analysis using
these kinds of methods so
again starting from the t bioinfo
platform that you just saw
we will
go through some example pipelines that
students build
they build those pipelines to understand
the inputs and the outputs behind each
step as well as the logic of analysis
how can they apply the right combination
of scripts and methods to achieve the
desired results and all of it is very
intuitive right as you can see there's
no coding involved
in addition to that the platform is
color coded and this color coding
follows a logic that we explain in
detail throughout the training program
itself
to apply those methods we then introduce
several different projects for example
cancer macrophages modeling cancer
precision medicine pdx tumor in the
micro environment but also
elements of infectious diseases like
malaria infection or even applications
in biotechnology and agriculture like
potato drought resistance for modified
crops
so that gives you an understanding of
the specific skills or specific methods
that need to be used and the specific
applications where you can actually try
and run that kind of analysis and see
what are the results what type of
insights you can generate analyzing such
data in addition to that we then go on
to one of the you know
maybe most exciting areas of
transcriptomic data analysis which is
single cell rna-seq analysis and we also
have a very basic processing pipeline
as well as a downstream analysis
pipeline for sailrat and monocle that we
go from the logic and then apply all of
the logic in terms of code that could be
run
on google cloud platform using google
colab
so what happens is that you understand
the logic the need and the reason for
specific methods and then you can apply
the specific portions of that code to
try and modify and get the types of
figures that you might need for a
publication
moreover you will then see how the exact
same approaches are used in high impact
publications that are
really transforming our understanding of
different domains
from cancer to neuroscience using such
techniques
so again
the objective in such a program in such
a basic program is to introduce the
specific type of data
the methods that are typically used to
analyze such data and then showcase some
of the
applications of that data analysis
including multi-omics integration
another type of a program that i want to
briefly speak about is bioinformatics
for infectious diseases so one of the
things that really happened over the
past couple of years is that even people
who had no understanding of you know
mutations variants
evolution and and things like that
really now know this terminology and are
even interested to try and uh you know
ask questions about the huge amounts of
publicly available data related to the
pandemic but also as an extension of
that related to many other types of
epidemics or outbreaks that could be
occurring and so what we did is
a couple of years ago we worked with the
virologists here at the louisiana state
university
understood how their expertise in
virology and bioinformatics could be
used for
creating these training modules and then
continued our collaborations with
researchers at ucsf stanford louisiana
state university georgetown medical
center as well as other regional centers
for example a large research consortium
on malaria to create project examples
that illustrate how similar types of
analytical methods could be applied to
analyze data and understand these
outbreaks of infectious diseases
so in this program we use project
examples related to the enterovirus
evd68 which was an outbreak that affects
primarily younger children and happening
recently in europe as well as in the us
malaria infection
again endemic in africa but also in many
regions of
south america i believe and uh in asia
sarskov ii which we all are continuing
to observe as well as the ebola virus
epidemic that not only started the first
public and connected collection of next
generation sequencing data that is
publicly available
but also produce solid results including
vaccines and antiviral drugs that
treated a disease that was 90
deadly before that
so as an extension of that we also offer
a focused analysis of source cove 2 as a
training module that many of the
research institutions that we work with
can use immediately because a big part
of the
sequencing and
big part of the research questions
around source code too um are regional
and so by working with institutions like
louisiana state university where we did
many different projects on source codes
too including wastewater sequencing
we can
train
you know students and researchers to be
able to perform the same and ask
questions of the publicly available data
and so
on the learn portal that you have just
seen
you will see
this kind of an overview that gives the
basics of multiple sequence alignment as
well as the ability to ask questions
about origins of source code 2 or how
the new variants are emerging and how
they might affect the future of this
pandemic
so at this point i briefly want to
introduce another element that i think
is critical for those students that are
serious about their interest in
bioinformatics
and what we see
uh time and time again is that students
going through short-term training are
unable to capture a lot of the aspects
of
bioinformatics the application of
bioinformatics but also the ability to
independently
learn and continue to apply
bioinformatics once those resources are
unavailable
and so for that reason we wanted to make
sure that many of the same methods that
are available through such training
could be taken away with the researcher
or the student after the program
completion and they're able to replicate
and even use those in their um
you know reporting or
ability to analyze data and so i briefly
want to show you a course that is
designed to kind of give you a broad
understanding of how this portal works
and that will be introduction to
bioinformatics so if you go to
introduction to bioinformatics
sorry uh bison molecules is what i
wanted to say okay so bites and
molecules
uh the bites and molecules course
uh really covers many of the aspects of
what we just discussed for someone who
is a beginner and has minimum or no
background in bioinformatics wants to
understand the terminology that is used
in such training and wants to be
prepared with some of the technical
skills that are going to be needed
and one of the courses that will be
available in this
section is an introduction to coding
so coding
is an important part of a
bioinformatician's
you know day-to-day life and activity
but it is often seen as an exclusive
skill set that only bioinformaticians
and engineers really need to have but as
we all know in many aspects of research
just to produce the picture that you
need the figure
maybe some simple data analysis with
some statistical properties it is always
useful to be able to
know that piece of code that if you know
how to run it you know how to give it
the right input you can make it produce
the right output that you want and that
is exactly the objective of some of this
very basic introductory training that we
offer in this section called
introduction to bioinformatics languages
and this one is an example using r
so here you will find some very basic
things that you need to understand about
data how it is stored and how it is used
in the coding environment but we don't
have to set up a whole environment on
your own system to be able to run and
produce even the basic plots that you
might want to use in your research
publications or exploratory analysis of
a data set that could be very
informative
so we offer here
inside the actual lesson a console that
you can run
and get result
right here
and as you can see immediately if i just
run this piece of code i am getting an
error
and the reason is because obviously this
path to the file does not work right and
so one of the basic challenges that all
of us probably faced when we started
learning how to code i can learn how to
write hello world but how do i actually
make this code work for my data right
and that's exactly where we start so
just by copying this link
and replacing it right here in the
console
i can run the code
and i can get some results right and so
right here you can see that
i can check the result
and now i have a successful result right
so i need to learn about some of the
syntax just some basics of writing how
to code i need to understand the logic
of how to find the right data and give
it the right link and then once i do
this console will check for me whether
i'm doing the right thing
and now i can extend this to more
advanced applications like running a
script to prepare a box plot or maybe
changing the way that this figure looks
right and eventually i will be
introduced to a an assignment and that
assignment will be right writing a
complete piece of code right so if i
know that i can complete this assignment
i'm not only following a step-by-step
tutorial but i'm in fact able to apply
what i have learned and now i can copy
this
and use it on my system to be able to
run that every time i face a result so
what kinds of activities are possible
for this type of
learning
one of the training that we do
in terms of source code 2
is performing multiple sequence
alignment and phylodynamics of the
pandemic outbreak in different regions
to really understand the emerging
variants or clades that have been
reported throughout the course of the
pandemic so as you can see the logic of
analysis is first done on the platform
and then we actually go through a series
of steps to generate a variant report
and this is a report not unlike what
people use when they use clinical
reporting or or when that reporting is
being uh submitted to um you know maybe
public health institutions to understand
whether there is a particular variant of
concern or maybe there are some number
of samples that you know indicate that
there's a spread of that bearing of
concern so we go through preparing such
a report
in r how to install all of the different
tools that are needed on your own system
and then how to actually run that with
the specific types of variants that you
might be interested in so it really
provides an ability to apply the logic
try it on publicly available data and
potentially then apply the same to novel
data that is being collected now we
don't stay at the sequence level we also
try to incorporate the association
between sequence and the structure so we
look at the spiked protein we understand
the spike protein and even map the
mutations and understand the
relationship between the proteins so
that we understand how they are
interacting and as a result understand
the significance of some of those
variants and all of that is done in
under a month-long training program
now another big part of what we do
going beyond the traditional
bioinformatics where we deal a lot with
sequence data and visualization is
actually learn about data science and
for data science we have this very basic
introduction that i just showed you in r
and python but we also want to be able
to apply some of those methods of
exploratory data analysis statistical
analysis machine learning
in a more advanced environment and so we
created this program to offer um you
know greater insights into what is
possible just knowing some of those
basics
again this is project oriented so we
start with
seemingly simple challenges for example
in the context of precision medicine can
we identify a patient that is likely to
respond or not respond to a particular
type of
medication and then we use that
information to be able to explain some
of the additional downstream
requirements for dealing with bigger
data how you can use different packages
how you can produce advanced
visualizations how you can apply similar
approaches to different types of data be
it genomic metagenomic transcriptomic
and others and eventually how to also
apply this using machine learning uh you
know advanced statistical analysis and
an understanding of how to apply these
skills to bigger data sets
now we've recently completed a program
like this that was you you know all of
it was designed around python
from very basics
to more and more advanced types of
applications where we also highlighted
the significance of
an online cloud-based environment to be
able to write
reproducible code and i think those are
two very important trends that students
need to be introduced to
as they move into the application of
bioinformatics or data science to
particular types of research not only do
we need to be able to extract meaningful
insights we also need to know how we got
those insights and provide an
environment where others can easily
reproduce the same code that we write
which means that the code needs to be
readable which means that we need to
explain what we're doing and why we're
doing that and also highlight the
results
with a piece of code that somebody can
take and
run and and get the exact same thing and
so there we cover things like uh you
know
dimensionality reduction
ordination and embedding
we look at different types of
classification models including the
understanding of how those models work
and how principles of those
logistic regression for example methods
are used in
more advanced methods like deep learning
and also
connect that with again practical
examples and those practical examples
could be used for
projects that have made a significant
impact so after we cover this domain of
machine learning we actually take a look
at several different publications where
all of the methods that we cover are
explained in the abstract itself and the
student can really see and appreciate
how the
specific outcome from some research
really affected
the
industry or even the clinical use of
those methods so for example here
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer is a project that we use to
illustrate individualized and
personalized treatment as well as
predictive modeling to understand
potential response that does not require
data from that patient themselves over a
course of different types of treatments
right which is obviously not possible
and i think very relevant to the medical
field which is moving further and
further into the adoption of such tools
and the precision treatment of
different types of complex diseases
now
beyond this training and i'll i'll be
done here in a couple of minutes
we offer
to use the same elements that i've just
described the t-bone info platform for
no code bioinformatics the coding
elements that you can embed right into
your coursework your expertise in
projects by illustrating a specific type
of a method in application to a data set
that you understand and might have
published before
as a resource for researchers and
faculty that would like to incorporate
their own training and make it available
to the nepu network so one of the ideas
is to identify gaps
for example if you take an institution
that might not have a full
bioinformatics
core
and they might not have the
you know facilities to be able to
support bioinformatics and computational
biology research
we would like to match them with another
institution that might have those
capabilities but might be lacking
another capability that that university
does have and so by linking those we're
able to address the gap across the whole
network
one example that i would like to show is
a course that we designed together with
dr sono vasudevan
she is the program director at the
georgetown university medical center for
a program called systems medicine and
her special is her specialty is in
bioinformatics using 3d protein
structures and really
kind of looking at the relationship
between sequence and structure
and so we worked with her to create a
summer course
where her students and students from
other
backgrounds could join and and learn the
basics of genomics in the virtual lab
we also worked with researchers that
specialize in oncology uh developing a
program on precision oncology and
we also kind of design these together in
collaboration with other researchers and
faculty and we are hoping to expand our
network and really uh kind of build the
same model of
the context the methodology and examples
of applications using curated data sets
to expand the library of resources that
we're offering now we've done these
programs over the year
the several years now
in several different institutions
we do have a lot of kind of feedback
from different users including students
faculty researchers and we are starting
to work with industry as well not only
to provide the basic training
and the path to research but also for
students that are interested in a path
to an industry career right where
bioinformatics is a highly desired
profession and skill set and can really
make a difference in someone pursuing
that direction
so thank you again for listening to my
part of the presentation it took a
little bit longer than i anticipated but
i would like to pass this on to dr mohit
mizunder who will speak about some of
our ongoing programs that we
have started in january
and are now available
to the nepi community for free
throughout 2022
thank you india and hello everyone it's
it's an absolute pleasure to meet you
all
um so uh today
i'm going to talk about the
opportunities and i think many of you
would be interested to learn about those
opportunities upcoming opportunities
that you can
[Music]
that you can participate in so is my
screen visible to all of you
okay so um thank you for that detailed
overview india and uh i think um uh what
we were trying to do is also to simplify
this entire um training
using uh modular tools and intuitive
multi-omics platform that you just saw
we are working with the students and
researchers and we are providing
research support and also big data
analytics tools designed for biomedical
data discovery
ultimately we are working for a future
where we where we can contribute to
enhance human health and well-being
through biological research and
discovery with the data uh solutions and
support and uh like as i as you already
saw in this during this presentation
what we are trying to do is that we are
trying to close the gap between for
research and discovery by utilizing
skills
that that have been developed throughout
this training period
with different training programs that
are designed specifically uh to achieve
some of the meaningful outcomes that we
are uh highlighting
along with the application learning
about the application of these different
uh
new areas of research
so um
all of this starts with very basic so
it's it's uh very simple it's just that
we start from very basic uh course work
then we learn about these different data
types and then
at the same time we learn about how
machine learning or data science or
programming languages plays a role in
downstream analysis and creating you
know better visualization and all of
that so this is the basic training that
we offer along with that there is a lot
of project project examples so this is
where it gets really interesting when
you are being able to you know apply
these these uh
learning into some real hands-on data
sets do some real hands-on exercises
learn about through the practical
examples so i did talk about all of this
many of these in quite detail and i i
hope that you have gotten understanding
and please feel free to write in the
chat if you have if you have any
questions um throughout the presentation
that you want to clarify and uh
again about the structure first of all
we are learning about the basic we are
learning about the different data
analysis
different data types and
their analysis then we are learning
through example projects and then we are
trying to work on these specialization
track projects so these are high value
research questions that we would want to
answer in collaboration with the faculty
or collaboration with the student
or a group
so about the steps uh these are the
different steps that we have very simple
introduction then some specialization
and some uh examples to learn about the
specialization and then to be able to
work on the specialization and now i
would like to tell you about the
upcoming opportunity that we've been
mentioning with the nappy network and
with lbr and lsu so we are piloting uh
we are not piloting we are just doing
the spring programs as we are doing
spring programs and summer programs
really some exciting bunch of programs
that helps
many to start their bioinformatics
journey to develop these different type
of skill sets so we have different
levels here beginners levels level
intermediate level and advanced level so
these programs will be available for
many of you who would be interested to
joining this uh these pro these uh
mental guided programs so you can also
see in this slide that there are a few
dates that are put together but we will
go to the pages the individual pages
where we have put together all the
information including the syllabus um
the dates that have the asynchronous uh
material that would be shared so it has
a combination of different elements as
you as you could see in in the previous
presentation paelia he discussed about
the courses
uh we discussed about i showed you the
project examples so these have
combination of all these resources uh
put together as a very innovative
syllabuses uh in a meaningful way that
lead you from basic training to
different specialized training and to be
able to you know
start working on real data sets so uh to
tell you about the first program
introduction to bioinformatics is just
to get you started with bioinformatics
this online training is designed for
everyone including students who do not
have any background in bioinformatics so
we will learn in this program we will
get an overview and learn about the
processing sections such as genomics
transcriptomics for analyzing and
interpreting omics data and that will be
followed by uh using machine learning
technology uh techniques to interpret uh
more uh insights from this data so this
is a basic program that would help many
to get started and in this
program we will also cover various
public repositories so how to find data
uh what are the different file formats
that are uh that have application in
biological research and then it would be
concluded by annotation visualization
and interpretation of the results so uh
the entire uh concept and the entire
idea of with this program is to get
everyone started give them an overview
of different sections that are available
on the tbi info platform that you saw
along with that
with every session we will have
asynchronous material so there will be
course course work associated with it so
bytes and molecules and bytes and
molecules and introduction to
bioinformatics course then getting
started with bioinformatics and ah
getting started with bioinformatics and
python and there are then nine case
studies that we will cover uh during
this
program
now i'll go into much more detail about
each of these programs and i'll show you
that
we have put together these pages that
you can uh check
and see the dates uh
uh for your availability that uh that uh
that will help you decide to join the
program and get trained and also like
these will be done
through a mixture like a hybrid program
there will be asynchronous sessions most
of the sessions ability asynchronous
where will be where we will be sharing
with you a video and
the online material as well as the
assignments and all the
collab notebooks and all of that that
elia was just showing you but here are
some dates the where we will have live
sessions and these will be
at uh 1 pm cst time uh but i'll again
we'll go to that
in the next few slides but before that
let me also tell you about the data
science program so in the data science
program which is again would be
we will be using uh
python and our
and we will learn throughout this course
student will get an understanding of
opportunities and limitations of machine
learning in the context of pre-clinical
and clinical research this course is
designed as a combination of online
resources as well as the practical
assignments and the live workshops so
all of these omis logic programs have
these elements
and in this uh throughout this course we
will review several project examples
that demonstrates the successes and
limitations of
conventional machine learning methods
and deep learning and we will be using a
lot of
data sets that we have prepared for you
to go through and understand and
understand like the challenges that we
see
when we use these methods not only just
uh to learn about the application but
what are the real challenges that you
face when you start analyzing your own
data which is something that is not uh
covered otherwise so this will have a
lot of sessions from feature selection
gene uh gene signature construction to
regression and generalized linear models
network analysis uh and as i said deep
learning and then
um
learning bio ml
and doing the course work as well so
there will be also a special coursework
specialized coursework associated with
the data science program then we also
have you opportunity for you to join
these programs the basic data types
which is like to learn about genomic
analysis if you're working on genomic
data or if you have interest in working
in genomic data then in this genomic
program we will cover ngs genomics so we
will go through sanger and wes and wgs
and then we will learn about the dna
code and the copy number variations then
we will learn about the genomic sequence
alignment and analysis and we will try
to visualize them
through different browsers and popular
tools that are available not only
through the tibia info platform but uh
the
free uh publicly available resources
then we will learn how to analyze
genomic data using art and then we will
work on um
different pipelines that we have put
together like uh uh genome white
association studies that which will
which and again there will be a lot of
case studies here we will discuss
special case studies from cancer
infectious diseases and agriculture so
that would be about the genomics and
then there's an also an opportunity to
do metagenomic uh data analysis to learn
about metagenomic data analysis which is
really uh come field that is coming up
and showing us those different type of
associations that we were not even
looking before so learning about the
microbiome the
functional bacterial community 16s rrna
metagenomic sequencing
ribosomal rna hypervariable regions
operational taxonomic units i'm just
discussing about the keywords because uh
you will have an opportunity to learn
about all of them in much more depth
throughout these programs and also to do
not only just learn about it but also
practice this and you know run pipelines
like uh
kind to uh data data to pipeline for amp
amplicon sequencing then we will look
into the sra and hmp and american gut uh
american gut project human gut project
perhaps the viral genome detection
through you know metagenomic data uh
looking at the evolution of fitness or
quasi species
all of those things are
kind of covered in this
we also look into the brain gut excess
and how the gut microbiome affects uh by
diet and uh the effect of you know
fertilizers uh to drug resistance all
those uh interesting projects are
covered and you know research ideas are
being discussed in this uh metagenomic
program so that is a brief overview of
all the upcoming opportunities that that
all of you have an opportunity to join
uh and i'll tell you more about these uh
these programs
sorry um so because it is almost time uh
for this session
maybe i could post about the
registration process yeah could you just
paste the links in chat as well
right so this is the link uh or just we
has already shared i'll request
rogersville again maybe share this link
so uh please go to this link and you can
fill this form that you can see on the
screen and choose the program that
you're interested in if you're
interested to join multiple programs
then you can obviously check two check
boxes but we will recommend you to
do as per your availability
so you have options to check
these
fill this form and our team will reach
out to you with the
all the information that we have
discussed in this meeting and all the
links that we have been discussing we
will also share these links to with luis
and i hope that luis can also
maybe help in sharing those links with
the students who are interested in the
faculty who are interested but if you
reach out if you can fill out this form
in this page on epic.org training
resources in the second page then we
will be able to
send you the details via email also so
please look for our emails many times
this end up in spam or different uh
filters uh so please
do check for with some of these keywords
and you'll be able to see the uh find
the email in your uh inbox and uh you
will be able to learn and get all the
links that are required and we will be
sharing with you the meeting links once
you registered so you will get access to
different resources that we discussed
today and followed by this these courses
uh one of the purpose of doing this is
again to be able to learn about these
different type of data types and then uh
to be able to work on a research project
so in the summer we will be doing uh the
research will be uh uh we will be uh
providing opportunity to all of you to
work on your own research proposals uh
that would be high value research
questions that you uh that you already
are maybe working on or that a question
that you would be uh you know
proposing after the training that
happens quite often many students go
through this entire process and propose
really amazing questions that could be
easily
[Music]
that you can easily
learn about or maybe thought about when
you go through the data sets explore the
data sets go to the publication there
are several ideas that keeps on coming
that one would be interested to explore
so that opportunity would be available
in the summer through the research
fellowship program and again
this program will have certain um
objectives that we would want to
showcase as an outcome to be able to get
a poster presentation to be able to
showcase in different uh different uh
conferences and to be able to publish
also so we also have a coursework
associated with that and we have several
of these case studies and uh previous
students who've been able to complete uh
through this research fellowship program
and showcase their results and publish
their results so all of this opportunity
it could be
also through this omixlogic research
symposium where we are bringing together
students
faculty researchers and industry to
discuss about recent advancements in
omics data and bioinformatics there will
be a poster session there will be uh
prizes uh there will be uh
internship and career opportunities
those all those things will be discussed
in the research symposium so we will be
glad if you many of you could also join
this symposium which will be freely
available to all of you who are
interested so uh that is what we uh kind
of plan today to show all of you then we
have a lot of research collaborations
where we are working with different
organizations who are providing us with
mentors and additional support that
would be helpful for many researchers
who would envision collaboration uh in
the future and uh similarly uh as i said
that these are our spring programs
followed by that we have our summer
programs where we have all these
interesting programs coming up for you
to take in the summer once you complete
uh your basic training and you'd be more
interested and
it will be more relevant for you all of
you so thank you all for your time and
i'll now pass it on to elia to conclude
the session
thank you yes i want to address some of
the questions that i see here in the
chat but before we do that i know that
it's the end of the session i see some
people nicole
pasting some evaluation links i don't
know if you want to
speak about that or jose did you want to
say anything
okay so
there were two questions that i saw in
the chat one of them is
to speak about what kind of
uh data will you be able to access from
your students let's say if you offer
this as a special topics course
so in fact many people start with a
special topics one credit course
to give an overview
and
what we provide is all of the activity
data uh for those students so i'll just
uh i already showed the profile but uh
briefly
you will be able to see
all of the activity
which for example
goes on to show
what kind of assignments have been
completed
what are the specific issues that the
person faced and all of this across the
whole time so you can actually go and
check what was covered in that
particular lesson so there's a lot of
activity and all of this activity feeds
into
the types of courses that are completed
what those courses covered
as well as certificates for any of the
coursework that were completed fully
that will also be available so as a
faculty you will have access to all of
your student data
so that was question number one question
number two that i see do you offer
special assistance in your courses for
mac users
i'm a mac user so you can see
here we have everything designed around
online tools first of all so as much as
possible we try to avoid any of the
technical limitations of different
systems and configurations that is
typically what any trainer would spend
45 percent of their time is
troubleshooting
and that's why we try to put as much as
possible online
after that we provide specific tutorials
on how to install and configure your
environment for mac users for windows
users for linux users as well so if you
have any specific questions
we can definitely help you with that
i think those were all the questions one
important thing that i want to clarify
is that all of these programs are
available for free
for those that are members of nepi the
way we count members of nepe is if you
are at a university or a research lab
that is somehow funded through the idea
program uh then that makes it uh a part
of nepi um and so if you can specify
that in your application um that would
help us uh kind of match you with that
account
thank you everyone for inviting us uh
and we hope to see you all again in the
training that is coming up and i'll pass
this on to jose
thank you
and also uh dr mazumder thank you very
much
for this very interesting orientation
informative seminar i think we have lots
of things to talk about
uh and follow up on and i want to uh
ask our our public uh
we have uh uh remaining in the chat 35
participants i want to let them know
that
these uh orientations will also be uh
repeated in some of our other
uh network institutions uh luis asked me
to mention that uh some of the anahim
mendes institutions will be hosting this
uh
this orientation so if you if you didn't
get the full
uh or you uh presentation or if you want
to just get a repeat to you can log on
to the p r i n b r e puerto rico imbre
uh just google p r i n b r e and you'll
find uh
uh the uh information uh for the next uh
orientation here in puerto rico
so uh thank you so much and uh
we look forward to interesting
collaborations with pine biotech
in the future
thank you very much and again thank you
for inviting us and we will continue to
look out for those of you that uh decide
to participate thank you okay have a
great afternoon thank you everyone for
attending and we it's time to sign out
now so
uh we'll see you soon in the next
seminar